Short and sweet, khazar number one.
We began learning this semester that there's a concept of tamke iker,
that the flavor which is absorbed into the walls of a keli, of a utensil, is considered like the food itself.
So if milk is absorbed into the walls of a pot, and then meat would be cooked in that pot,
we would consider as if the milk and the meat was cooked together,
and assuming that the pot was a ben yomo, that it was used in the past 24 hours for milk,
the meat that was cooked inside the pot would be asr da araysa,
Just like if the actual milk and meat was cooked together.
We then learned about the concept of Nat Barnat, which is in a situation where a par of food is cooked inside of a pot,
which has some sort of flavor absorbed into it, whether that is meat or dairy.
The par of food, which is now cooked in this pot, in this utensil, absorbs flavor from the walls of the pot.
However, through that absorption, through the cooking process, the flavor is degraded and it is somewhat weakened.
And the power of food is now called a Nat Barnat, a נותן טעם בר נותן טעם.
All opinions agree that once you have a Nat Barnat, whether of meat or dairy, it would be allowed to be eaten either before or after the other type,
and it would also be allowed to be served with the utensils of the other type.
So, if a person would eat a Nat Barnat of meat, they can definitely eat dairy immediately afterwards,
And it could also have that of a not-bar-not that was cooked in a meat pot can be served with dairy utensils.
A common case and a common question that comes up is when a person wants to mix a not-bar-not with the other type.
So a classic case that we will use would be a person is cooking pasta, par of pasta, in a fillet-shaped pot, in a meat pot,
and they then want to use that pasta with cheese.
So it's going to depend a lot on the status of the pot.
We'll begin by discussing the case of the benyomo fleshig pot, if the pot was used in the past 24 hours to cook meat.
So, if the person is right now in a lechadchila situation, they are pre-doing anything,
they plan on cooking this part of pasta in a meat benyomo pot, and their intention is to serve it with dairy.
So according to the Ramah, this is forbidden.
L'chachila, this is asr, a person cannot do this.
According to the Shulchan Aruch, it's a macholkes, there are those who said the Shulchan Aruch holds it's forbidden, while others, or Rav Ovadya says it's permitted.
And in a case where it's, let's say, a b'dievah, they already have cooked the pasta in the fleshyk pot, and now they want to air dairy, so this is a macholkes in the Shulchan Aruch and the Ramah.
The Shulchan Aruch holds that since the pasta is already a not-bar-not of fleshyks, it can be now mixed with the cheese.
However, the Ramah holds, נותן לחכילה, we cannot mix a knot by a knot of fleisheks with cheese.
A third scenario would be if, let's say, a person had already cooked the pasta in the fleishek benyomah pot,
and they already had mixed it with cheese, and they come to the rabbi and say,
what's the status of my pasta with cheese?
Everyone agrees that Shulchan Aruch and Ramah both agree that the food is b'dievet, post facto, permitted.
Another scenario would be if a person now has an eno benyomah fleishek pot.
This pot is meat, but has not been used in the past 24 hours.
Okay, so then we have the same three scenarios.
If a person would want to cook pasta in this Einu Ben Yom HaFleshik pot in order to mix it with cheese,
the Shulchan Aruch holds it is permitted.
Everyone agrees that in the Shulchan Aruch's opinion, this is permitted.
In the Ramaz camp, that's a Machokas, the Gra, the Vilna Goan said it's also permitted,
the Ramah Gris is permitted, while the Chochmas Adam holds that a person should not do this if they have a par pot available.
But if they do not, then even the Chochmas Adam says a person can use the Eno Ben Yom HaFleshik pot to cook par pasta and mix it with cheese.
Let's say a situation was that a person already had cooked the pasta in the Eno Ben Yom HaFleshik pot, and now they want to mix it with dairy.
So then everybody agrees that's permitted as well.
For sure, if a person had cooked the pasta in the Eno Ben Yom HaFleshik pot and had already mixed it with cheese, of course, all opinions Shulchan Aruch and Rama would agree that it is permitted.
We mentioned that a very important point about Nat Bar Nat is that Nat Bar Nat only applies to Basar V'chalav because the whole understanding is that when the meat or the dairy flavor inside the pot gets transferred to the par of food, it gets degraded and it's not anymore have its full potency that can become Basar V'chalav.
However, if let's say an utensil was used to cook something forbidden, and then a part of kosher food was cooked in that forbidden utensil, the flavor does not get degraded. No matter how many times the flavor gets transferred, the flavor is already forbidden, and all the food that is cooked in that utensil is forbidden. And if that food then passes on its flavor to something else, it would also be forbidden.
We lastly mentioned that if you find food with a DE, a dairy equipment, on the label, that means that the food is a not-bar-not of dairy equipment.
There are some products marked with a D, which are actually parv, but they're marked D for other considerations.
In general, a person should never rely on the label of a food, and we should always call the cautious organization and find out if something is truly dairy or is it dairy equipment.